oh [ __ ] hello everybody welcome to the
very first episode of genius brain
podcast I am Davis this is so [ __ ]
weird dude this is bizarre yeah my name
is Davis oh and uh yes yes yeah and I am
wait am I supposed to introduce myself
or is this I like traduce you don't
worry about that [ __ ] my name is Davis
so this is the genius brain pot death
the cool thing about the genius brain
podcast is that this podcast is about
anything and everything you can give you
life advice we could talk about some
serious [ __ ] current events whatever you
guys want basically at the end of the
day I'm here to accompany you throughout
your day and it's nice because I'm doing
this at home so I could basically wear
whatever the [ __ ] I want and that's
exactly what you were doing
so today special guest on the genius
brain podcast is my roommate and my very
close friend Khalif Boyd yo-yo Khalif
bored in the building I feel like I'm
like Charlemagne the God or somebody
actually is it roommate or is a
housemate I've been hearing a lot of
people say this in my house make some
European [ __ ] is it I think so oh
you just don't like it
shout out to Europe yeah you know you
know unis hmm so if you guys don't know
who Eunice is Eunice is was the Wardrobe
I would say wardrobe consultant I
actually don't know the exact title of
what she does is she's gonna be super
upset well she basically dressed
everybody on set on Guk so as you guys
know I'm not traditionally an actor I
don't know these [ __ ] terminologies I
just made a movie and I just act on [ __ ]
that's about a hill that she well when
it comes to like specifics I don't know
[ __ ] about it but basically with her she
lived out in Europe for I don't know I
think for like five or six years and she
came back and also she's saying all this
our appeal oh [ __ ] she goes I'm gonna go
back to my flat
go back to your flat
you're going back to your apartment
bitching of [ __ ] I mean what did she say
she was like oh oh she said I'm in the
mood for some over jeans some what I
said exactly I said what I said what's
the over Jean I suppose that a you be
are [ __ ] and basically that means
eggplant she was looking for eggplants
and I guess that's how they say it on
the UK oh my eyes she and I I think
specifically she was choosing words that
would know so she could make me feel bad
about myself she was like I'm in the
mood for some aubergines and some rocket
rocket is a arugula in Europe what so
I'm gonna get some over jeans a rocket
in my [ __ ] flat
you [ __ ] yeah you can't be using words
if you don't know the history but cuz I
can tell you some [ __ ] make you
sound stupid when you go back to America
100% trying to sell you know it's
similarly back in his culture and I had
this uh.this homie in high school his uh
he moved to Hawaii I guess a couple
years after we graduated high school and
mind you he grew up in Sacramento
California his whole life
I mean the dude has a Hawaiian ass name
but I think he moved to Hawaii for like
four or five months and instantly he had
a pidgin accent this fool was ridiculous
dude four to five months he was oh hey
bro the kind brah the [ __ ] out of your
brother like you moved there for four
months you sure he went to Hawaii and
didn't watch fruitful station I feel
like a lot of people were like you know
why watch Bravo station like people are
saying breath breath breath breath same
breath you need a snot that [ __ ]
brothers like the the hot thing right
now everybody uses that turd now be are
you H bruh I know even [ __ ] um
Instagram dude you given like use a
little sticker and I was like bruh and
like cool Tim really fun yeah
and what the interesting thing about
social media now is that I think when I
first started when I was first in this
space I used to think of it as I didn't
like people like swagger jacking people
you don't say so like if if there was
like a a certain way that people from
the west coast would say something and I
would see that bleed into other areas I
would think they were being really fake
with it like why are you saying that
[ __ ] are you saying just because it was
popular but that's just my old s way of
thinking as social media has blown up
and everybody is on it with whether
these kids are growing up with YouTube
they're growing up with what's it called
that that [ __ ] that disappeared vine oh
yeah those talented people who a vine or
whatever that they saw there they're
they're listening to that [ __ ] and it's
being absorbed in them so there's no
real like you can see that and dance -
so like depending on whatever coast that
you're from like you would have like
this like Wescoe swagger to you or you
have that
that East Coast type of ship with you
when you see death is bleeding
everywhere now everybody's dancing like
everybody else everybody's singing like
somebody else and nobody's really having
that like unique vibe to them like they
used to I mean this still is not like
they used to you know yeah it's like a
factory pretty much it's just like
accessibility and like self teaching
yourself and call yourself a dancer and
creating your own thing and then you
find out there jagging somebody from
Brazil so [ __ ] yeah yeah you success
ability it's just like oh [ __ ] yeah
there you go do this okay cool but yeah
I mean just like it's scram just like
the saturation of it and allowing like
like memes the new hieroglyphics yeah
it's just easy to like truncate and make
it easy and acceptable because I think
that's most people millenials are
talking like that you know what's so
funny though what pisses me off is when
I see on Facebook when an adult makes a
meme that they think is really funny
this is not funny at all you don't I
mean like they they found out what it
may may is yeah I'm doing mayonnaise too
and they do like some kind of political
[ __ ] like the hottest thing I think
for old people to do is to go on
Facebook and do some politics memes you
know yeah yeah that's like the thing
right now and it's just like it's it's
so reversi you said oh my god can't
believe like my parents on social media
they just sent me a meme of John Wahb
gleaning backwards in his see insane
bruh
it's like I don't know I think I'm gonna
be coming that old person though real
soon enough so why don't you go ahead
and let people know what you so if you
guys don't know Khalif is actually a
full-time actor like he has been acting
in the scene for a very long time and I
think like so basically what I want to
do with this podcast and is kind of have
conversations with people so I think
that when you guys listen to a lot of
podcasts you think that these
celebrities are the only people with
interesting stories won't be for people
who came celebrities they were just
regular people to you you wouldn't even
notice them if they were walking down
the street but everybody has an
individual story and Oakley for a long
time and I and I think that especially
after was to call like crazy rich Asians
I've been getting hit up by a buttload
of people saying that they want to
become actors so instead of hearing it
from me telling you what it is to be an
acta because I've only done it for about
a year it would be kind of nice for free
for you to talk about your acting
experience yeah my acting experience is
I just recently discovered it was just
my it mean everyone's journey is unique
and in my case like a few before even
before you knew me like I was super
quiet like I didn't express myself and
going even further back before that when
I was 18 like growing up I had a mom or
I have a mother who's deaf and a father
who's super stoic his inability to
communicate on a deep level to share
with me to help me find my own voice
wasn't there so and we had basic
television that was limited to me and I
didn't have so much too drawn from my
imagination I mean I had I had Hooked on
Phonics couldn't read that well you were
on hooked on phonics but Braille yep I
made it all the way to the brown volume
I don't even know what that is cuz I was
too smart for that [ __ ] oh man it's like
these cassettes with these workbooks and
just like like reteaching you man it's
like a supplement to what to my homework
that was getting in elementary school
you got didn't help you like try to read
it [ __ ] no man the old way he taught me
had her know he really did it
you know whenever he took me to library
he would go up to the magazine section
he would well first he would walk me
over to the children's section
I find the librarian she gives me a book
goosebumps baby-sitters club Sweet
Valley High and [ __ ] whatever and then I
would want to take this book home and
hoping that my dad would read it to me
but instead he was showing me his jet
magazines or ebony and like the Tom
wasn't that a study [ __ ] he was looking
at downtown Julie brown and whoever else
named camel totally totally he was that
weirdo in the corner
but no shame you guys like six-foot-five
- he's hard to miss yeah
slowly totally it's definitely a
cerritos ones no majority is asian
people and uh it's very affluent city
and him just be in the corner trying to
figure out how to get on the internet
and not doing that he was just in the
corner reading his magazines you told me
your dad speaks Vietnamese dude which is
[ __ ] wild dude I know that is a very
sweet bookmark in my life if he hadn't
done that I would not exist my mom again
like I said she's deaf and she only
speaks Vietnamese and when my father
came back from New York with a little
stint trying GoPro blue I his knees
rolling one basketball right yeah yeah
that's a sound so when he so you saying
when he was he in the NBA then or was
object he was like tryouts like oh [ __ ]
yeah so he was right there he was right
there yeah and then he's a CEO um no he
actually he had a when he was in high
school he was working at alpha beta D
November alpha beta what the [ __ ] is
that it's like a save one save one yeah
yeah yeah I think there's still save on
still his day really I don't think so
really I don't know I think save on he's
still around if you are sponsors do that
do we need that yeah he was opening a
box with a box cutter and just missed it
and slit his knee he had like 26 dishes
and ever since then it just wasn't right
and hold so he tore up his knee not even
playing basketball I mean he did it got
it got weakened yeah like yeah but
essentially if that wasn't the root
problem of why my father had to this
doesn't he know when you open up a box
with supposed to go away from your body
so he put the knee he put the Box on his
knee caps the one thing that's so
precious to a basketball player you like
you know what I'm gonna take this chance
today yeah cuts box so he lost his
career through a through a box cutter
that was the start of it
then ya don't even know that she'd be
this [ __ ] hilarious
sad it's a very sad but if it didn't
happen then again I wouldn't be here but
my father came back his homeboy hooked
him up with a job as a beer truck driver
at the time I'm I was working at a meat
market Hawthorne with the family that
brought her here from Vietnam and then
he found out that my mother only speaks
Vietnamese and so he wants to go take
night classes to learn that's [ __ ]
crazy dude and that's is we can't open
up a box correctly but he can live in
Damascus true it doesn't make sense my
life does not make sense man it doesn't
make sense but uh yeah so um my dad
tried to live his dreams through me
playing basketball and that [ __ ] burned
me out and cuz I played in Taiwan and
Costa Rica
I lost my passion and again with
basketball I was I was like Tim Duncan
like I was a silent leader yeah
led by action I wasn't passionate in
that way or mouthing off
so when you went when you went pro you
went pro international semi-pro
you know semi-pro internationally when
what did it to be a semi-pro basketball
player like what is that what's the
difference between Pro and semi-pro Pro
is like Pro is like mmm
semi-pro is like more sponsors I mean
it's kind of announcing MBA you see the
sponsor logos and awesome it's
essentially the same thing yeah but so
it's like it's like semi-pro is like the
NB do or is that right it is a semi-pro
is like is it's like all those
international days that [ __ ] they're
like team at play for and who like t-mek
like when t-mek oh no no that's like
that's bro that's pro pro yeah that's a
pro pro that's like when you go to like
FIBA okay and like they send their best
national team you know players semi-pro
is kind of like to get on that team so
you before that I wasn't getting paid
like ball or a mouse yeah and like no
decent amount okay yeah but I mean PDM
we get housing did you want to go to the
NBA I did yeah I did that on a way is
not a hella sad dude I did I did I did
but then again I'm grateful that it did
because I realize after playing Costa
Rica man like the amount of practice I
had to like waking up at 4:30 in the
morning at having a little Tico picking
it up like the little taxis yeah
and just practicing six times a day and
I was like man if I really loved this I
would be enjoying this like this is life
is six times a day huh what's it like
what's what's a normal day like a normal
day I was like important 4:30 get picked
up have breakfast banana coffee whatever
and then you have routine philosophy you
have your weights conditioning then you
have team practice small guard practice
lunch break then you have weights again
then you have what do you do after that
break down tape a scouting report dinner
and then what do you do at an evening
die what the [ __ ] no we did oh we did
like a more place just more plays oh
[ __ ] yeah so you didn't enjoy any of
that I did for like the first like two
weeks
what made you hate it so much I mean you
did it your whole life I mean if I play
ball like you up you balling people up
no [ __ ] reason this is gonna I think
I did it because I discovered this turd
therapy I did it for my dad man I really
really loved my dad did it forget dad
did for my dad I mean I remember like
Saturdays without Phil like going to the
park and if I didn't make 30 free-throws
I just didn't go home oh man I would
have never went home you see me shoot
free-throws bro I was 32 now out of
until this age my dad just like you're
gonna make them free throws you see that
guy over there shouldn't be
and see that hole that he shits in
that's the best bathroom
[ __ ] allowed to go home if
there's that dude in the corner unit
burrito just watching them yeah bring us
home talk about del Taco did you have to
make that [ __ ] in a row no hmm I have to
be honest though oh [ __ ] I would have
liked him off yeah I couldn't damn dude
so you did that for your dad yeah did
you feel like you were doing that
because like your dad had a mishap in
his dreams and he was kind of living his
dream through you Oh totally totally and
I remember thinking about it now I
remember when la was playing a
Sacramento actually um the golden years
the golden years like my dad never
directly made me feel like I could make
the NBA like when he was training me and
making me just practice 24/7 made you
feel like you could have you couldn't I
he never really have like never told me
is like you have you know you got it you
know
like until probably 12 13 I guess I
think that's how old you were 14 15
we're pretty young
yeah because go to the times where it
was like neck-and-neck I was super young
cuz I was watching that [ __ ] at the
house by myself and when we would win a
game bro out [ __ ] around the house
what's that oh it's scream I was
screaming like a dumbass jump on the
sofa out the window what was that
[ __ ] dance move where you would grab
your [ __ ] ankle though running no the
running man I would anybody manage it
also had high that wasn't a running man
is it right a man's like that that's the
running man [ __ ] we drank me do this
yeah what was actually no idea what
that's called yeah that was that was
that was the [ __ ] that I was doing that
[ __ ] yeah but my mom would come and
she'll be the [ __ ] oh [ __ ] are you
uh-huh
why would she boy we should beat you up
oh yeah there's no dancing allowed in a
Korean house thank you happy yeah should
have study but but back to that like I
remember Mike baby he had like a crazy
ass game and I was like damn back baby's
like six feet like I'm you know I'm like
510 like or I think I was like [ __ ] yeah
I was like 510 it's like I'm gonna go
outside and like practice and I was
dribbling between my legs I'm a dad came
you say you know what you might slip
through the cracks oh [ __ ] that must've
made you feel good yeah yeah dad
actually gave you a compliment what the
[ __ ]
I bet still hasn't given me a 30 [ __ ]
years dude that wasn't said thank you
I'm sorry
and good job yet I'm still waiting for
that [ __ ] that was gonna be in his
deathbed I'm like dad right before you
leave just say I did a good job he's
gonna reach out his hand gonna be like
there's a [ __ ] you I know you go home
yeah a podcast like a piece of [ __ ] yeah
yeah so like that this that's kind of
tells like speaks how my father was with
me just very little words that's why I
didn't teach you how to read he was
trying to Johnny shoot that's why it was
like [ __ ] education shoot the goddamn
ball yeah if I can't read I never I
never ever heard my diary does that fool
when he gets a text message goes come
here boy absolutely not he had a pager
he refused to have a cell phone until
his job forced him to oh [ __ ] yes so I
think he didn't like being reached out
having to be that mediate you know all
having to respond to assist somebody
based on their time or based on their
time and I hate that [ __ ] do those yeah
that's true but you're [ __ ] but
you're not you know father that's true
you should probably do that a wife
that's uh yeah yeah you might want to do
that yeah this is good this is this boy
but yeah um yeah so just like growing
old and like not having basketball like
making that realization that basketball
wasn't my number one so when the [ __ ] is
it and so my friend saw me moping around
at the stereos town centre I was like
hey what do you do now I'm like I don't
know man
maybe I'll just work for the parks I
teach kids how to play basketball use
like maybe you should try out my acting
class I'm like okay cool that sounds
alright so then Tom Armony
at Cypress College
he took me in and saw something in me
and then told me to take acting classes
with him out in Burbank which sounded
like Tarzana to me at the time cuz I
didn't really go out to LA like that and
I didn't really have friends out in LA
like all my friends are playing overseas
in Germany or China whatever so I didn't
know anybody in LA so I just took my
little Scion and he told me like as long
as you don't miss a class like this is a
scholarship opportunity for you so cool
you know saved me 400 bucks a month yeah
I just drove out there swept the coat
you know swept the theater and took
classes and slept in my car you know and
so wait when I met you how long were you
acting for and when did you stop when
you when did you quit your semi-pro
career semi-pro career I was like 2009
2009-2010 okay and then you came back at
2010 yeah and then I met you 2011 so I
don't make you a year after that yeah
it's true though you were sleeping in
your car dude my house yeah yeah yeah I
was living to a car like it was not good
Burbank Police like good people good
people they would like tap on your
family window sure yeah yeah and then
yeah I remember my teacher he'd draw a
practice station wagon right behind my
car and he like looked and he's like did
you sleep on your car I was like yeah
he's like that's dangerous I'm like I'm
alright no the cops the Burbank Police
cops like that I mean yeah they're yeah
oh [ __ ] okay yeah so that's a like kind
of like find my way around different
neighborhoods or if I met a friend just
kind of like hang out there until late
or maybe which is what time was class
class was like 9 o'clock in the morning
till like 6:00 cuz all day it's like
pretty much like school that's [ __ ]
crazy
yeah damn acting class takes that long I
don't know I'll take that [ __ ] you look
like everything it's kind of
conservatory like we did like animal
work like for like an hour like what you
like this animal work chant like did I
say a mammal animal I don't know animal
work is like
you pretend there's a tiger then you
feed him about know you you pretend
you're the tiger you sleep [ __ ] is that
that just opens like your animal
instincts like you man you find your
animal like your spirit animal like the
you could experiment with like being a
giraffe like when's the giraffe look
like do you extend what kind of what
kind of person holds himself to that oh
man I be that [ __ ] in class I'm doing
this [ __ ] you'd be like yeah you
probably we're doing animal work today
so what are you gonna be I'm gonna be a
human being you [ __ ] [ __ ] tell me
what to do not you run me over like you
would be that that orangutan from jungle
book but the reggae take the top I'll
just be sitting on my chair just peeling
bananas thrown at you [ __ ] go
ahead yeah you gonna rob me of that
animal work what else would you do
animal work we do the classics like he
introduced me to Shepherd like Tennessee
Williams goose named Shepherd in
Tennessee Sam Shepard was like fulfill
of Tennessee Williams it's like a
streetcar named desire you see that [ __ ]
people that's knowledge of act this was
saying a bunch of words I can't string
them together right now he says he said
he's a fruit fruit fruit for car streets
car Street of fruits deep [ __ ] you well
you know streetcar named desire
I know the name you know I know I know
of the those words together I don't know
what it's like a streetcar named desire
you know remember streetcar named is a
spin-off of cars the animation they have
a car named yeah yeah yeah so you would
do so did you know were you studying
film prior to that though prior to going
into acting did you know a lot about
film or absolutely just [ __ ] empty so
you were me I was you okay yeah yeah I
was you like out I just felt like I
asked so much to catch up um that's term
in terms of film and then I saw a film
called a beautiful with Javier by name
yeah yeah exactly you know that is
that's right javi about Deepa's to do
that by time
my uncle's from from Skyfall is that
Skyfall no is this guy fault is that the
yellow 7 yeah the bad guy with the
blonde hair
that's right double-oh-seven yeah is
that what that blonde do with blood and
[ __ ] there will be blood no no I'm not
there we bled the other one
damn what movie is that you can't look
at me I know who Harvey hunt Xavier he
has like the bold cut and he has like a
oxygen tank and he's like a assassin now
you sound like you're talking about
[ __ ] hector salamanca from my hector
salamanca from [ __ ] what's it called
Breaking Bad is [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh my god
can't believe I can't remember that
movie do it I don't even know but see
when I don't remember movies it doesn't
kill me like that they're like you know
this actor I'm gonna abso-fucking-lutely
not I still don't even know who [ __ ]
Morpheus his real name is from Road ages
80 track Morpheus Parkers Laurence
Fishburne told you I know what I'm
talking no I know I know
because Laurence Fishburne looks like
Abe's dead good lord Fishburne looks
like a dead you didn't pull a picture up
I don't know I forgot he looks like let
me show you that [ __ ] oh my god alright
Fishburne's really nice I saw him at a
Whole Foods
I was memory him for matrix I'm pretty
sure he is obviously his career is a lot
more than the matrix but not to me well
blackish oh that's right he's [ __ ]
doping blackish uh-huh her Laurence
Fishburne's
daughter does porn I was gonna say that
but yes she does she does wait no is
Laurence Fishburne it is yeah it is it
is it is definitely it definitely is
Laurence Fishburne and I'll see if
Laurence Fishburne was an angry Korean
man this would that's exactly what I got
to go on this was face
Laurence Fishburne's daughter does do
porn that's so interesting I wonder what
made her go into the life of pornography
she's an actress I'm pretty sure that's
in the same line of is it oh it is it is
that's the same line of act it's hard
man not that I've done it
it's hard I have respect for porn stars
Laurence Fishburne that do you tell me
that's not Laurence Fishburne if he was
a angry Korean man he even got that
tooth gap to the actor that made the
tooth gap popular yes made everybody
feel okay with little [ __ ] yo I could
have a tooth get a horse Laurence
Fishburne done he still had it
he deserves I think he still has it
Horace Fishburne got the acne scars too
which I didn't realize it is it's yeah I
saw the matrix when it was I was like
[ __ ] digitally remaster [ __ ] and that
[ __ ] stuck out the pits yeah the pits
Laurence Fishburne you know what the
[ __ ] is name is spelt with L is Lau it's
not a you oh [ __ ] salmon delaford bro
yep he's still got the tooth gap dude
that fool maybe I should help popular
man who are our other famous people at
teeth gaps all I know is this like when
you were a kid and you had tooth gap
basically you're [ __ ] high school
career was over
oh would be just cracking jokes and yeah
all the [ __ ] time yeah baby had a few
like jump rope to [ __ ] you are flashing
teeth would you get that jump rope it is
carry a jumper are you the worst that's
right kid you know worse kids would go
home you quick I were you cool quick at
making fun of people I had when I was a
kid all right
just because I grew up in a
predominantly black area and so if
you're I mean our our area too would had
a lot of Asians it was just really mix
it's just that I I kind of I think I
hopped around groups a lot but I know
like that like the black homies they
would [ __ ] crack jokes dude hmm and
there's so many at that time
specifically for Asian people there was
so many like Asian jokes that you could
say it no matter how bad the joke was
people could just clown on you left and
right and they would [ __ ] laugh so I
had to be quick with it
because
they say racist [ __ ] to me but I could
never say racist [ __ ] back rec us as bad
you know what I mean yeah well I had a
super [ __ ] fast with it
yeah when somebody would clown on me I
would have to clown on the bow to clap
back real fast right and put a filter on
it exactly so I would have to be really
crafty with my words you know what I
mean I think that's why I wanted to be a
battle rapper too much material for
people to make fun of it once your agent
and you're fat you basically can't be a
battle rapper
give him the [ __ ] blueprint like 24/7
yeah but that was like one of those
things that I like I remember I was just
like do these people gonna come at me
and say something stupid so I say
something stupid back and the problem
with that is too if you say that [ __ ] to
a thug they just kick your ass I still
climb on your stupid ass man yeah I did
not have that skill whatsoever I relied
on [ __ ] buying that your mama jokes
off the scholastic trolled my order and
like you guys so much danger if it's a
snow storm like I want bad bro I had to
not know how to disappear well you were
you tall
oh absolutely now small oh really I was
well I wasn't right but you went to UM
you went to a very accredited high
school oh yeah we had a Pulitzer Prize
winning author come to our school
because the title of the book was school
of dreams by I think his name was Edward
Humes but he sounds [ __ ] smart as
[ __ ] yeah man and were huge Humes he
would just sit out in the back of the
room and just watch teachers interact
with these students because these
students would come from very rich Asian
families like these problems we'll all
buy homes in these gated areas and then
Whitney Whitney yep Whitney [ __ ] me
Whitney like I don't know anything about
like this so yeah I don't really care
about education growing up at all
whatsoever right so I'm here dude yeah I
could give a [ __ ] less like I didn't
know anything about like number one what
blue ribbon schools were I didn't know
any of those terminologies I only found
that out now as an adult because I
talked to Bart and Joe because they grew
up around that [ __ ] I really did it like
for me it was like in Sacramento there
was what floor and high that was Laguna
high that was McClatchy there was these
type of schools and I just do that some
schools have more white people in it
some people didn't and there was
a couple of other like private schools
like Christian Brothers a [ __ ] like that
so I didn't know about how the education
was so much better at specific schools
like it Whitney hi when people hear that
you were from Whitney high they go oh
you must have been a smartass kid right
right which I didn't [ __ ] know and um
like Julia was telling me stuff about
the school that she went to I'm not sure
if it was Whitney high but it was some
kind of like a very academically
accredited high school where academia
was the [ __ ] yeah Newsweek or like
Huffington Post to do like the top
schools in South County you know yeah
like people would get made fun of if
they didn't get like a a is she that's
what she said like if you came back and
you did a test and you tried your
hardest and you got a B they'd be like
cut look at this [ __ ] loser right
complete opposite if you got an a you
better run your ass home like I remember
in high school there was those kids that
would have those roller bags oh yeah
right they would they would just I would
see it the bell would ring they will
walk outside I hear click on like run
little [ __ ] yeah
that [ __ ] was so bad because the noise
of those wheels was the signal and the
sound of how they would find you to kick
your yeah yeah yeah and I would look at
them like just [ __ ] rot it's like a
little kitty bell it's just like like
just [ __ ] what are you doing yeah you
know that's gonna beat you but they're
smart because they don't my scoliosis
that's true my back's all [ __ ] it's
true history I didn't have a roller
backpack I was trying to [ __ ] blend
the [ __ ] I had that one [ __ ] but
JanSport what you possession and what's
it called when gap started selling
backpacks of [ __ ] had one of those I
selling that [ __ ] over to my back on one
side and then I [ __ ] had scoliosis
[ __ ] was beat up that's true you got
makes our cash prizes did you do you
have a current favorite actor right now
current favorite actor right now yes I
do is marshal ax Maher Sheila Alli
Michelle
Ali so that's the dude from [ __ ] dude
I'm blanking out spider-man he did the
voice-over [ __ ] piss me off yeah yeah
that's not talked about yeah very close
to getting a role on that and I didn't
get it so whatever we watched that film
and I went to that film hopefully hoping
it was trash and it was probably one of
the best I've seen this year but
everyone's lists
I refuse to admit that it's amazing
though because even after the film was
done I was like garbage and I just
walked out I may say everybody
hurt me - I was like wasn't that film
[ __ ] [ __ ]
it would have been great if they had an
Asian character in there you guys are
garbage it must be really good now that
[ __ ] suck yeah I'm probably gonna buy it
because it was really good but yeah I
need a watch - it was a dude I can't
believe I'm blanking out on the film dad
the movies in yeah I didn't know I know
the one and I don't want to say how I
know it because I'm about to use
adjectives for it to see what the movie
is but don't be mad at me but he was in
the gay gay movie where there was three
stages of gayness oh it was the the it
was showing what this child was going
through figuring out his sexuality right
so I'm not trying to be offensive but
that's just how I remember that's how I
guess that's how I did school is when I
did notes of [ __ ] that's how I remember
stuff I would use stuff like I would
double up the words gay gay yeah I was
gonna go back to that what is gay gay
gay gay it's just for me I say gay gay
because that film had levels of gayness
in it in terms of not in a offensive way
what I'm saying like the story of his
homosexuality he was gay as a young
person being gay J figure out his
gayness in the middle and then he was
figuring out his adult gayness when he
looked like 50 cent
I know it was a bit was it was it was
cinematically beautiful it was amazing
well [ __ ] [ __ ] I should know this
because I watch this film my two three
times um
don't don't tell me don't tell me what
it is man it was the air it was such a
beautiful film to be able it was so
[ __ ] beautiful
dude I should know this but I liked this
film a lot I know this was it started
give me the first letter the first
letter yeah M am easy dude
monsters ball I know if it was F what
you think it was gonna be huh fairly
synonymous its oh god I don't [ __ ]
know what's the second letter oh oh
monsters ball no it's that's monster yes
right let's go back to that monster's
ball that's uh wait no that's not
Charlie Stan that's when Halle Berry
showed her titties right yeah for like
20 a pop yep that's what it was that's
cool
do you see how I remember things people
is gay gays and titties yep so what's
monster's ball Halle Berry titty yeah I
keep it very simple but moonlight was
[ __ ] be you too
oh I'm a clean beautiful man I love like
I love Barry Jake it's just how he
focuses on just love just love like you
know what if Bill Street could talk or
like I haven't seen it yet I've read the
book I want to go back and watch the it
was the gay gay movie that put it on the
spot which one uh Malik and Rover back
no don't you know what actually I
haven't seen that movie you know what
I'll put it to you like this I'm gonna
be as honest as possible on this podcast
when I was younger I tried watching
Brokeback Mountain and I could not do it
cuz I couldn't watched two guys [ __ ]
like it was just I was just so
close-minded at that point but also as a
heterosexual male I think it's just some
kind of weird [ __ ] for me to see you
know what I mean really yeah totally and
so like I just couldn't watch it I think
I was like a little I'm gonna say
prejudiced per se but kind of growing it
own up in an area where homosexuality is
kind of made fun of a lot you know you
know you call people gay and you hear
the word you know don't call people
[ __ ] and stuff like that watching
that film I didn't want to be the dude
in the group that watched Brokeback
mountains yeah you know what I mean I
get to say well movie watchers I wash it
broke the [ __ ] you asked for men defense
but I did try watching and I couldn't go
through it but I feel like as an adult
because I do appreciate acting I feel I
think I could watch it with the new lens
right right that's all about yeah cuz
Brokeback was the one that put it on the
[ __ ] map oh yeah totally
it was a lift that was also with some
nice pair of titties
it was the the girl with the big ass
eyes I mean and see it the the female
actress with the big ass eyes and the
fair a skin she was a the princess is
the in the film called the princesses
princess or something yeah she was is
where she was like a slug dog and she
became a princess slum dog then became a
princess she's white it's not I want to
say it starts with a H but I know it's
not Halle Berry and I want to say it has
to do with a cookie and Hathaway uh uh
Anne Hathaway yeah that's right it only
was it could be because I was thinking
about that and cookie thing that's right
Anne Hathaway and Heflin cookies I'm
eight Inez and these cookies that's
right that's how you remember it that's
how I remember and cuz she's sweet like
a cookie she isn't that sweet like a
cook ya matter and she lied about what
who she was what'd she say I actually
want to go see a creme Bailey Rae and
Jimmy Kimmel you could have been with
her too I'm hoping this [ __ ] up later no
I don't do that man - Cyrus bah
I don't know I don't get flood you know
what my girlfriend she laughed at me cuz
she went to my room back in Lakewood
uh-huh and I have like I still have my
little cream Bailey recurrent cream
Bailey Rae is a career in Corinne I
could not know her [ __ ] I don't know
maybe I don't know I don't know but I
have like a shrine like posters in the
corner of like the other pictures I took
with her and she is like oh my god like
it see and like it's like yeah why can't
I not have a crush on ya Corinne because
she's jealous dude it's because she's
also a musician and you don't have any
[ __ ] pictures of her like that with
her [ __ ] music that's true I mean she
had an accent Corinne Bailey Rae man you
could have had a nice date we thought
you guys say you can bring that up
a bit later like in five seconds you
better tell me about the crib Bailey
race no matter to Ma Peche a Corrine if
you're watching this which I guarantee
you're not because you look like you're
a classy intelligible human being I will
say this though this man he's taken now
but back then he should have taken his
chance with you he should have asked you
out on a date and he didn't and he liked
you too he loved you he still loves you
what happened you tell that [ __ ]
so um I was on a lunch run at work and I
went tomorrow's this is what I first
started working for this entertainment
lawyer in West Hollywood and he's like
what do you want for lunch I'm like I
don't know it on those area like yeah
let's go to I don't know five guys he's
like no let's go tomorrow's it's pretty
fancy over there and you could check out
that's not Paul Mitchell
anyways that's not important anyways I
I'm going there to pick up an order and
the second I get out of my car like
she's probably like 50 feet away I just
see the back of her head I did you see
hacker no black hair I'm like that's
creamy larae with a doubt I know that's
cream Valerio she had a guitar [ __ ] yeah
that's like SR started walking closer
and closer and closer and then I look
side I to her and it was her I'm like oh
[ __ ] cool I go to the front desk go pay
for the lunch order for the office and
they're like oh we actually need to fill
one more order we forgot to put in your
you know to go so can't just hang out
for a couple minutes am i cool so the
only suit that was available for me to
wait was right next to cream by Larry's
table and her I'm assuming as a
publicist and her manager yeah I think
she was in town recording her new album
that just came out was it called like
green an aphrodisiac or some like that
so I'm beautiful
something beautiful yeah it's always
beautiful
I get the hutzpah to say
hey um I'm a fan yeah we've actually met
three times I met you at the House of
Blues I met you at the Troubadour and I
met you at the for theater all
coincidental stuff and I met you
actually for because Jimmy Kimmel I know
I'm in her for x and then her friend was
like Oh see like he's a Fed like he
remembers you she is like cool cool and
uh they were I guess they were recording
at Capitol Records oh and I was like oh
and I just started falling you Instagram
you actually liked my photo with Maxine
like we're on top of yeah you're on top
of all do you want to Instagram no no
she did not follow me she liked one of
my photos that's the same [ __ ] to me
especially yeah went this is for shame
and I got she broke a thousand followers
like she just was so curious about the
medium and she liked it and she she
finished my sentence before I am told
her what photo she liked I was like you
like my photos that my Dutch I know and
then he was like look see your social
media it's working uh sir I'm just there
talking to her is like oh you know we're
recording at Capitol Records over there
um was it vine oh yeah right I don't
know um some would like what are you
doing I'm like I'm just picking up lunch
it's like Oh like you should still like
you were gonna eat here I was like yeah
I gotta go back to work those like oh
why did you tease like eat a sandwich
with to eat lunch that's my [ __ ]
dream dude you know what that means
I mean she was interested in you I know
nobody [ __ ] looks at somebody says
hey oh I just seat you either sandwich
with nobody nobody has ever offered me
to sit down and have a sandwich with
them ever even fans I know I can't no I
can't separate cuz it in the back of my
my mind I knew about her her husband her
husband passed away yeah and I was like
this may sound insensitive it's gonna be
insensitive he's dead alright so at that
listen listen rector dude I understand
but at that point it's been quite a few
years when you matter it's been quite
almost few years a few years yeah yo
homie rested peace man you had a very
beautiful life I heard you were a
musician as well you were a jazz
musician I heard he plays some kind of
jazzy ass instrument and I'm pretty sure
you guys had a beautiful relationship
rest in peace on but what I'm trying but
what I'm trying to say is you dead now
it was your time to shine not yeah he
would he would been haunting you like
that [ __ ] doing on big mouth but you
uh you did not have lunch with her and I
have lunch with her and I went back to
work like I'm back to work and then I
sent you the picture you're like I'm so
disappointed in your newest artist I was
so [ __ ] disappointed if Corinne
Bailey Rae said hey I want you to go
home right now
I want you to get a wet towel right I
want you to soak it in butane and I want
you to like you're [ __ ] neighbors
children on fire oh I would have done it
in a second you know what to be honest I
would - that's difficult [ __ ] hate
the exact know you want to get into
stories about yeah that's another
episode man if I can don't spit no don't
spare the rod yeah I'll tell you that
right now
I'll kick those kids in the [ __ ] face
I love you kids though you guys have an
ability to change anybody can change but
not those kids [ __ ] them no no that's
terrible
you had a chance with Corinne Bailey Rae
you didn't [ __ ] take it yeah and
that's why I became an actor exactly
full circle so right now are you argue
if you okay this is what I really want
to ask just because I've had a couple of
friends come up to me they asked me am i
okay so how do I become an actor and I
can't really explain that process I my
brother cliff told me you ain't got it
told me you sir no I'm just kidding
actually he never said anything like
that
yeah potential yes potential so what
would you tell somebody will be the
first steps man the first steps take
class take class okay I'm uh I'm uh I'm
gonna pretend to be
everybody that wants to be an actor I
gotta go these are the type of
conversations I gotta go and what's up
doc cuz I'd uh hey so like real talk man
yo man I'll be seeing you do your thing
right right so I've been seeing you out
there and I've been seeing that yo you
made it homey I'll bet you made it man
you made it out of Long Beach but you
made out of Long Beach yeah I'm saying
you made it out there y'all seeing you
out there doing your [ __ ] back
fresh cuz so Real Talk you want to be an
actor too uh so like how do I become an
actor though alright first of all I like
a personality okay yeah yeah yeah you
know so just start off um if you're
living in LA uh I live in LA okay to do
that I'm down yeah but you had to go to
Samuel French okay who the [ __ ] is that
Sam your French is a place that a lot of
actors go to take your place okay and
then there's a little book that tells
you what schools are to study yet and
there's yeah [ __ ] acting class don't man
what I'm trying to do trying to be real
quick all right I'm trying to be an
action star right right so what I did I
took up six boxing class I took up six
boxing classes all right okay I'm gonna
start there real quick so how do I
become an act door I want to be an
action star you guys think I'm [ __ ]
around this is an actual conversation I
had with somebody you think I'm [ __ ]
around this is the actual conversation I
had with somebody that's that's sad
this [ __ ] told me that he wanted
to be an actor so so he took a
kickboxing he was like I feel like a lot
of Asian people out there they don't got
they didn't like me you know what I mean
there's a lot of Asian people that's not
doing martial arts it films really
gently Jackie Chan you piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ] sigh Crouching Tiger so he
basically told me that he wanted to be
the next biggest action star and I you
know I gave him the couple of options I
was like do you want the real advice or
do you want the fake advice right I want
you to give to me real was that cool
number one it's the dumbest [ __ ]
thing I've ever heard like if you wanted
to be a [ __ ] it go take a [ __ ]
acting class right and go take an acting
class so you want to be an actor so you
take a kick
in classroom [ __ ] what the [ __ ] does
that mean man it gets muddled like it
depends on who you talk to it's like you
know people like people get so obsessed
about like I want to be really good at
this craft I want to know yeah the ins
and outs of it I have to be in class but
people forget to be a human being and I
really know who they are yeah and you
know you do here in an acting class like
you'll if you step in and awed it and
you see an actor in class who has a
different cold T expressing themselves
they're gonna like go take him go take
some kickboxing classes okay you know
get that anger out you know that makes
sense this thing was that he wanted to
learn how to fight so he could fight on
screen so I'm gonna do that I started
out kickboxing so he could be the next
biggest Asian action star because
there's never been an Asian action star
ever you dumb [ __ ] cuz the problem this
is the problem that I have with that
right it's like okay so there are actors
right now that are Asian American that
are [ __ ] killing it in the scene
right so they can they can do what you
do already and then on top of that and I
felt bad for saying this but I don't at
the same time because I did mean it I
was like here this is what it is man and
I'm just gonna be real with you
actors right now they take acting
classes they'll do all the stunts stuff
in whatever as an ancillary thing but
they start with a good foundation also
dude you're ugly
so now yeah now you trying to be the
number one action star we're all whole
movie is based around you and you were
one of the ugliest [ __ ] I've
ever seen
and I'm not the best-looking dude on
earth and if I call you ugly you ugly as
[ __ ] so so let's let's just break that
down real quick okay and I just told
them like it's kind of disrespectful
that you think that you're the next
biggest thing out there you have no sex
appeal you have you just don't have the
sex appeal you don't have to [ __ ] your
work ethic and on top of that you're
[ __ ] on other actors work right so
they they're putting the ground work in
there I'll be a really dope they've been
doing it for years and they still
haven't been able to crack that rule but
for some reason you're gonna do that
they're gonna walk in that [ __ ] room
and people are gonna be shocked I was
like they're like yeah they are gonna be
shocked at how ugly you are
you're [ __ ] hideous like you know
maybe like I'm but I'm the ultimate man
I
we actually have to bring somebody else
in for that story but there are these
human beings that just don't understand
the the hard work it takes to enter into
a craft yeah like so nosy
they think it's the easiest [ __ ]
thing on earth and I think that's the
the problem that I have is just because
not so much in my career but just
because I've I've only done auditioning
and acting for a year and it was it was
such a hard thing for me to grasp and
understand just because acting alone
isn't just that one part of that craft
it's everything that meant that it
entails you know and somebody who comes
in I think they like it for the glory
right they want people to say yo I saw
you on that commercial that whatever
10-second spot you I saw you on that TV
show
yo bro you made it really you [ __ ]
heaven I know friends right now that
have been on network television shows
mm-hmm right they were like whatever a
reoccurring guest star 1015 [ __ ]
episodes right they're still living
paycheck to [ __ ] paycheck and they
don't understand this [ __ ] they don't
get it they see oh that person's on TV
they're ballin you have to realize how
many scripts are put up how many TV
shows go up how many TV shows don't get
made a casting director told me it's
about 2% 2% if it gets made and in that
2% pull that gets made you are somehow
going to be casted over tens of
thousands of people that are around the
world around the [ __ ] world by the
way around the world that's the type of
poll that you're going into but for some
reason me the ultimate man was taking a
kickboxing class teach him how to act
it's gonna be the action stone right and
I think like for him he was kind of like
a little shocked you know what do you
would you mean man you say like I don't
you know like you had to start somewhere
all that yeah I did have to start
somewhere you're absolutely a hundred
percent right but your path in my path
are different I never said that I was
the missing link I've never ever said
that one there's so many actors that I
look up to that I'm trying to be like
right now so much emulate their acting
style but I respect the craft so much
and I understand the road work that it
takes down there you know and I've never
really actually put it out there that
I'm an actor because I'm really not yet
maybe I will be in the future but who
really knows I had
really committed myself to that craft
and for that person that really had that
conversation was kind of irritating
because I know actors like you who are
putting in that [ __ ] work you
remember the first time I had my first
audition yeah you called me I called you
just devastated as [ __ ] yeah you're
crying and I was not crying you better
his [ __ ] though so basically what
happened with this so I got signed right
I got signed to an agency after [ __ ]
blew up it was it was such a crazy turn
of events like I signed to an agency
immediately they put me out and so I was
like you know I'm ready to go
I don't need acting classes yet could
just even before the acting classes just
put me out to an audition because I
learn on the spot that's the type of
human being I am I said that [ __ ] so I
read this script I get it like the day
before all right now is that oh this is
how fast it comes out I thought we get
like three or four days for scripts
which actually does not happen a lot and
they're like did not [ __ ] know that
so that's how good you have to be at
that craft so I I'm reading oh she's
like I'm practicing by myself oh this is
a [ __ ] funny a script dude I can
[ __ ] do this script real tight I go
in and I remember this room it was super
dark and they just had like it was very
interesting because that was the only
taped audition that I had that I had to
go into then the room was kind of dark
and it was like lit like that and I
think it was because it was so when I
walked in I'm doing the lines right
mm-hm I do the [ __ ] lines and I'm
expecting for people to laugh and this
is gonna be a funny ass [ __ ] thing
and she looks at me and she goes as I'm
saying my line her response I can't
remember her exact line but it was like
so how did you get murdered no holy [ __ ]
this is not a comedic squid spray and I
just I [ __ ] I just had a commit at
that point because that's all I
practiced so I committed and after I did
the audition she goes that was a very
interesting take and she was thank you I
walked outside I hit that [ __ ] that
rely button in my car and I said [ __ ] I
was so mortified I called this dude up I
was like bro that was the worst
experience of my life I did like an NCIS
like audition for like a technique
that's supposed to figure out how this
murder happened in a comedic
hmm I thought it was a comedy script cuz
I'm so used to doing comedy I read a
serious murder scene as a comic role in
my very first audition ever and you
learned and I didn't tell my agent that
either so if you saw that bro that's
what I did I embarrassed you okay would
you learn on the spot I mean at least
she had that know-it-all didn't know
that it was yeah I should I should do my
research a little bit that's exactly
what I've seen that's the things you
learn in class man do you remember your
first audition my first audition yeah I
drove all the way my first audition
my very first audition was like a
student film by tree that like it was
like the thing that thing thinks I drove
all the way out to the [ __ ] was I Studio
City or some like there right don't know
where I'm at go to this thing I get
paired up with a girl and she's from
Mexico and English is her second
language
okay and she doesn't know her lines as
you can't read her lives no and I'm like
holy [ __ ] I don't know what's gonna
happen like she doesn't know her lines
at all I don't know what's gonna happen
so I remember going in there the cast
nurtures like all right you guys ready
it's like we'll see how this goes and
she just improved the whole thing yeah
she improv and I didn't have any improv
experience I just didn't know I was
allowed to do that yeah yeah you know
and so she was super personality's super
making people laugh and I was like what
the [ __ ] I don't know so that helped me
understand that she knew what the story
was about you know the English that she
did have and she kind of liked it the
whole Sofia
whatever name is a Vargas from Mars Oh
Sofia Vergara yeah pagará
she kind of had that spice and that
personality and yeah like you know it's
it's it's charming ya know so for me I
was just freaking the [ __ ] out I was
like well she kind of [ __ ] you over
though oh that's big-time yeah because
when you it's interesting because when
you guys do if you guys ever become an
act and you guys start doing these
auditions what you'll find out - I don't
know what happens but instinctually you
start memorizing your lines any
responses based on the words that you
hear before and after so if you lose
those cues you've kind of forget where
you're at right right right and but if
you know the source so well and if you
can
like roundabouts yeah but I didn't know
the story so they look you over
yeah but my big like going on to the lot
like chicken with the security guard
like that experience it was great
actually
yeah you know because I had learned from
that I think the years it was like Oh
from that student film experience
yeah to like a big Network audition
probably like four years oh yeah so I
had learned so much from going to like
USC LMU UCLA just auditioning finding my
voice learning in class and then just
being comfortable in the room and this
owning it I mean confident and knowing
that's I know I need to know the story
another to you know push forward
actually was the hardest part like when
I would read these scripts and I would
hate it mm-hmm and I had to figure out
like a backstory you know and kind of
really understand these characters
because you know they'll throw like
curveballs at you oh yeah for sure and
on the spot oh can you read these lines
instead you know yeah and then if you
don't know the character very well
you're [ __ ]
yeah you know yeah but I remember uh
that [ __ ] audition that I had a tape
where I was supposed to play uh get
bumpass werewolf is [ __ ] oh yeah dude I
was died dude I was like [ __ ] asked me
to be on this [ __ ] thing where I'm
supposed to be a sexy werewolf I was so
wrong I was 265 pounds with wedyn
sweating through the whole audition and
it was taped in my own house you know
what I mean and they're like okay and
then I remember because my manager he
was like they just want to see that you
could do variety I was like come on man
I think it's supposed to play a 16 year
old werewolf a Taylor Lautner and I
think like I'm supposed to be shirtless
at a certain point in this big and this
will got the same audition I was like
yeah that makes sense but I will support
you I gotta I gotta find that audition
cuz if I have it taped somewhere but
that [ __ ] when I look back on it was it
the first like something that was my
first selfie I was yeah we're selfie and
it was like [ __ ] like 10 pages yeah
it was a hella long man was super long
it was the longest [ __ ] thing I've
ever had in my life and I think that was
the longest self tape I've ever had it
was
one of my very first ones and they were
looking for a young dude and I was a
struggling with Daphne yeah when you
crash it was so bad man yeah cell taping
this stuff and you would think that so
taping would be easy bird I don't think
that it is I thought man I think when
you go in it's better because they could
actually give you direction around what
they want right and when you sulfate you
kind of just have to figure it out like
through your own cuz a lot of the times
too when you go into these auditions
what happens is that you have your own
take on something sometimes just
completely wrong yeah but they like the
way that you said you think so they'll
be like do it this way right and if you
can't do that you follow yeah yeah if
you come in with a choice like you
actually they know when you've worked on
the piece yeah like they can like steer
you a different direction we've become
of like a dry ass reader like this
person doesn't even care yeah why would
I why would I put my creative and I
input on to someone who doesn't even
want to and best yeah so yeah man I
think like the hardest part of those
auditions like I had to come in
basically like I was trying to suck
everybody's dick and I hate that [ __ ]
not in that kind of sense like I wasn't
like desperate when I yes
yeah coming hey how's it go
yeah I'm doing great and you know and to
be honest with you that's just not who I
am as a person like what I would like to
do is come in do my line yeah whatever
slate if I have to and then get the [ __ ]
on out yeah that yeah will love that
hey how's it going my name is do
yourself do it to a southern Korean man
yeah I like away you know okay he'll our
man but you got you consistently because
I would help you realize or whatever and
I know when you had to do it on the fly
I would be there to help you realize
yeah yeah and the cool thing about it I
will have read like the stuff that you
get it clearly is for a very attractive
man and everything that I got was for
like a fat Mexican security guard sound
cast they would typecast me like a
[ __ ] but it was never for an Asian
person I really ever got an audition
that was meant for an Asian person it
was usually I kid you not I'm not even
[ __ ] with you it was for like a fat
Mexican person so we got this role this
guy's name is Haddad though and we want
see what you can do he you know and I
got a cup of callbacks on that one
absence rate yeah that's right it was
the one that I enjoyed a lot yeah yeah I
remember that one and I'd be surprised
it was like okay this is clearly not
made for me but I'm gonna see what
happens with that and then I Edition for
it and I got a couple callbacks but I
didn't get it that's so fun I forgot
about yeah I got a couple callbacks that
didn't get it you're like I'm liking it
this guys [ __ ] on guardo what the
hell yeah you what the funny thing was
to like dressed up as a security guard
mm-hm and then I was walking in the
parking lot and I was trying to get to
the audition and I was just lost cuz I
didn't know where to go and that was
well this guy was like hey bro you don't
work here that's like do you mean you
don't work here man nothing what I'm
gonna try to break into the lot for what
like what the [ __ ] bro did you go out
and buy like a costume I bought
everything dude I brought I got the
[ __ ] the navy blue cargo shorts
that's got the white collar shirt I got
the hat that says security damn yep I
[ __ ] committed they were cracking up
in the room I still didn't get it though
yeah you never know
look I don't know what they want it's
like you were laughing you ass you never
yeah yeah you'll never know man and I
did I didn't I didn't book a single
[ __ ] thing all year I just got a
bunch of callbacks that's about it you
didn't know I didn't book anything well
I got a voiceover stuff i but Moi's over
stuff cool right yeah so there was a
couple animated films that I worked out
did some work on and it just didn't go
through and it would have been great if
I was on it but whatever I was not
signed an NDA for that yeah cool
well it's out there the films out now
that's true yeah so it's thumbs out that
wasn't it so [ __ ] it
what they gonna do sue me for what sure
films out that's sure sure yeah because
I I think yeah cuz I did this like
footwork for Snoop Dogg I tell you about
this yeah yeah yeah yeah and I posted
that I was the feet in the commercial is
me yeah and some of from the agency was
like hey we need you to take that down
oh really yeah
what the [ __ ] yeah why does Snoop Dogg
need a foot double because it they
didn't realize that they needed like if
you see it like his feet is on the thing
and he's like interacting with the game
so it was like whoa like its feets
moving you know they didn't get that
footage I guarantee you I bet you is
because noob dog feeders hella pretty I
bet you that fools feet are [ __ ]
pretty it was like a size 14 dude then
again he's like six more he's like sick
he's huge man it was like clips with
this full boxing is [ __ ] at the age of
60 yeah therefore he still boxes like a
hood ass dude Jaidev she's a long-ass
day and he had a guy holding his mitts
that was five foot one holding his mitt
like answering a question is [ __ ] in
class yeah she was so [ __ ] funny - is
funny yeah man he says closer Wiz
Khalifa boxin no Wiz Khalifa's actually
dope that boy time man oh yeah boy I
would say dope in this is if I don't
know how he is when he spars and stuff
but I saw a couple of Clips like he'd
like me up like that would light me up
like I said dude he's [ __ ] yo yeah he
got a big man with his buff as [ __ ] yeah
was it like like Snoop if he was healthy
yeah you know it's true true that yeah
[ __ ] crazy how yolk tea is cuz Wiz
was [ __ ] skinny yeah he was scrawny
as [ __ ] Kevin Durant scrawny lon yeah
I was kind of surprised Apple taking
steroids I'm your [ __ ] you want steroids
bro
sorry not much weed smell me that what
yeah you ain't doing weed a scientific
fact not sure at all I don't know
science for [ __ ] but you were [ __ ]
skinny a [ __ ] too
yeah I was I was meows cat [ __ ] I
couldn't I just didn't know how to gain
weight and then I started taking this
[ __ ] Kali she would have known me I
would have taught you know all your
body's us unless sir you know it's
starving artists man I was like just not
eating in that amount of calories I need
to eat I was just not eat all day if I
wanted to man like I could sit here and
I could just eat all [ __ ] day I can't
do that I just can't but you went from
like 140
sounds like 145 to like 185 that's
[ __ ] crazy
yeah it's guy big and I did that I did
that for the vanity because it was like
a for commercial that uh my homegirl she
got me an audition for a PowerBar he was
like a big campaign with Blake Griffin
killed it
improv uh you know improved and then I
didn't get it and she was like yeah um
they liked you a lot but you're just way
too [ __ ] skinny god damn damn for oh
she's like yeah you just way too skinny
I'm like damn so then enough of that you
just started like getting yoked this
year so you took that motivation I take
that motivation I started taking the
enormous no I remember that she'd used
so this dude used to take this thing
called enormous and he would eat it with
a scoop of peanut butter some olive oil
and uh oh oh yeah and you and that [ __ ]
was it was like a 3,000 calories Weimer
you